hallöchen meine liebste herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung und zwar von der minecraft
mein painter modifikation hier vorne
schild schon creeper und ihr seht schon
was diese motto in etwa hinzufügt und
zwar einen kurzen moment nicht das ganze
jemand mit ihr das seht ihr könnt mit
dieser modifikation hier teile aus
blöcken einfach rausnehmen indem wir da
einfach mal ein bisschen da warum spielt
ihr könnt beispielsweise auch bilder
bemalen und so weiter und so fort und
ich erkläre euch jetzt erstmal so die
grundzüge von der modifikation also
zunächst einmal der downloadlink es in
der beschreibung und viele meinen noch
immer ich habe mir damals viel zu viel
zeit damit gelassen diese blöden
crafting rezept euch vorzustellen die
ihr euch einfach selber anschauen könnt
auf der website also einfach mal in der
beschreibung schauen da steht irgendwo
der download link unten dann könnt ihr
euch die casting rezepte und so einfach
aneignen ich möchte euch nur zeigen was
man mit den funktionen machen kann und
zwar wenn man sind wenn man ins inventar
geht steht schon hier sind wie immer die
ganz normalen alltag an einer seite
weiterblättern zur mine painter seite
dann sieht man hier stone scheessel
scheessel diamond survival jedenfalls
kann man diese schüssel dinger dafür
benutzen was ich euch ja in diesem blog
gerade gezeigt hat dass ich kann jetzt
die beispielsweise über den blätter bock
ist beispielsweise gerade nicht aber
irgendwie bei holz oder bei steinen oder
bei anderen blöcken gar nicht einfach da
hingehen und mal sagen ja ich möchte ich
hier so einen kleinen block house haben
und hier und hier auch und hier auch und
hier möchte ich einmal so komplett
durchgeschnitten haben und dann drehte
ich schon der block sieht dann
dementsprechend so aus unter fliegen
auch einige kleine teile raus wenn ich
diese kleinen teil letzte aufsammeln
seht ihr schon in einem inventar habe
ich jetzt beispielsweise 22 skepsis und
von den anderen zehn sculptures ist den
hier nämlich auch noch auf jetzt habe
ich beispielsweise 11 und das ist jetzt
beispielsweise schon so lange und das
sind erst auch diese kurzen also dass
hier sind die kleinen die ich aus diesem
block hier vorne vorhin rausgeholt hatte
was ich ihr seht da waren ja relativ
viele so kleine rausgeholt das sind
nämlich solche kleinen teile damit
können wir dann beispielsweise jetzt mal
so etwas baut einen kleinen mini penis
oder so und wir können beispielsweise
auch aus diesen großen stangen also aus
den anderen scampis können wir so was
bauen oder wenn wir uns einmal ein
bisschen niedriger gehen können wir da
auch
so etwas rein theoretisch braun ich
zeige euch mal eben was da eben läuft
vor allem rein theoretisch könnten wir
auch hier ein hinsetzen endet ihr schon
da springt an einer weg weil die er sich
hier quasi dann überschreitet und dann
kriegen wir ein von den kleinen mehr und
dann wenn man sich beispielsweise geht
das auch dann setze ich hier jetzt
einfach mal so einen mann wie geht das
denn da setze ich eine so volle ich weiß
gar nicht wie so dass ich da drauf
gesetzt hat aber ich denke ich könnte
auch einfach mal hier hin gehen und dann
da drunter noch einsetzen ja ja das geht
auch soll das gesehen und da könnte ich
hier mit drei theoretischen paar coole
sachen machen ich könnte jetzt auch hier
nochmal einen drauf setzt dann kann ich
damit seine kleine kuhle treppe mal rein
theoretisch bauen ist jetzt mal ein
bisschen blöd dass da diese stange nach
mitte ist aber ich denke ihr wisst was
ich meine da könnte ich dann einfach so
hoch laufen ich mache das hier oben
ich hab alles jedenfalls seht ihr dann
hier schon im inventar dass ich dieses
skating habe und das kann ich jetzt hier
einfach hinsetzen und dann kann ich die
ganze zeit so was komisches bauern das
heißt ihr seht dann beispielsweise wenn
ihr einmal so eines klar gemacht habt
ihr zerstört die dann habt ihr die auch
wieder im inventar
also das ist erstmal so diese hauptsache
der modifikation mit dieser tatsache
nicht mit dieser penta sachen dieser
tatsache dass ich quasi einfach aus
bestimmten blöcken wie stein geht meine
ich auch ja hier aussteigen kann man das
auch machen
die stadt kann ich mir entweder so ein
paar kleine blöcke rausnehmen hier
beispielsweise nehme ich mir da mal
diese kleinen raus oder halt diese
großen teile irgendwie hier raus nehmen
einfach und dann kann ich hier mit ganz
coole sachen machen dann habe ich die
teil auch in dem inventar drin und das
ist erst mal das was mit den schlüssel
teil machen kann auch richtig neu ist
diese kleine skulptur hier ist einfach
level png und dann habe ich halt auf
jeden fall diese teil im inventar und
kann daraus dann einfach skulpturen
erschaffen teilweise eventuell auch dach
bänder oder das sind dachziegel kann ich
daraus machen meine lieben freunde und
dann kann ich einfach hinsetzen genauso
wie diese skulptur die ich hier gerade
erschaffen habe nur halt noch ein
bisschen cooler kann man sich coole
sachen mit aus denken dass es diese
hauptfunktion der modifikation das hätte
hier schon das sind die puzzleteile die
kann man sich ganz einfach kräften man
müsse sich erst noch einmal so ein ding
machen dann muss man das ding mit einem
eisen zusammen hat man so ein ding und
dann das ding mit einem jammern zusammen
sondern hat man das diamond ding die
halten hat einfach ein bisschen länger
weil ihr wisst schon denke ich wenn man
ganz ganz viele von den kleinen blöcken
h
möchte dauert das lange die zu bekommen
und dann verbrauchten sich die
haltbarkeit extrem schnell
das heißt dass ihr kann ich mir erstmal
wieder aus meinem inventar entfernen des
machers ich bin so blöd so ich habe
jetzt die ganzen sachen hier entfernt
und jetzt sehen wir schon was denn als
nächstes kommt und zwar die rennski
ranch ist auch extrem idee und zwar
können wir damit einfach beispielsweise
auf eine skulptur drauf klickt und dann
können wir das ganze ding drehen das
hatte ich vorhin schon probiert
allerdings funktioniert das ganze so
dass funktion mit allen skulpturen also
ich kann auch hier auf den hier
draufklicken dann funktioniert das ganze
auch oder ich klicke auf einfach mal
hinten drauf dass ich schon dass ich das
da hinten drehen kann und da kommen dann
auch relativ komische sound immer bei
rom wer genauer hinhört
das sind irgendwie so sounds wie keine
ahnung nicht vom kolben aber ich weiß
nicht ganz genau auf jeden fall sind die
sounds doch irgendwo im standard sound
pack enthalten drin aber ich bin mir
grad überhaupt nicht sicher das sieht
aus wie sie ungefähr oder irgendwie
sowas überhaupt nicht sicher wo diese
teile im soundtrack darin enthalten sind
aber vielleicht wisst ihr das können
einen kommentar schreiben oder flächen
sondern eher die lehre gegangen
jedenfalls haben wir da noch diese items
die ich hier unten schon mal drin ab und
zwar den small brasch und den ganz
normalen brasch das zeige ich euch jetzt
erstmal hier ganz kurz an diesen teilen
die wir hier haben und zwar mit dem
smart brach mal ich jetzt hier
beispielsweise einfach mal in pink hier
beispielsweise auch in pink und welche
normalen branche nehmen ist das ganze
quasi nur ein bisschen größer wenn ich
den gedrückt haltet dann kommen die
teile halt ein bisschen genauer zur
geltung und wenn ich hier auf das pinke
drauf gehen kann ich dementsprechend
nicht malen aber wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal mit der palette auf
das grüne klicke hier beispielsweise
dann habe ich das grün als farbe oben
und dann kann ich hier mit auch auf grün
malen also diese palette stellt
beispielsweise einfach so ein bisschen
diese diese farbe da die ich noch in
petto habe die ich die einfach noch so
vorhanden ist
jetzt denke ich erst mal kann ich das
ändern gemacht die scheiße dafür braucht
man schon kennen das ist kann man sich
mega leicht kraft wie gesagt download
links und beschreiben da stehen ganze
pracht gesamtaufkommen wir einfach mal
diese teile hier weg machen und dann
haben wir jetzt hier einfach ein ganz
normales kenntnis und hängen dass sie
hinter sich das erstmal so außer denke
ich der favorit bin laden nach so
übrigens von vorhin diese teile die ich
gerade abgebaut habe die sind dann quasi
einfach als bilder gespeichert und die
kann ich hier dann auch wieder hin
hängen aber das will ich einfach nicht
weil die einfach hässlich vergeben
einfach sehr sehr herzlich ich nehme
jetzt aber erstmal einen wassereimer und
beispielsweise rosa farbstoff und auch
mal grauen farbstoff dann kann ich dir
nämlich hier zusammen
dann habe ich hier einen pay back at in
rosa und dann brauche ich noch mal neuen
wassereimer und packt ihn jetzt mal eben
mit dem grauen farbstoff zusammen wenn
ich jetzt nämlich wieder ein wassereimer
rheinpark und einen grauen farbstoff
habe ich jetzt beispielsweise einen
grauen paint bucket dann kann ich den
wassereimer hier mal eben wieder
entfernen und nun beispielsweise auf
diese scans oder ich nochmal ein zweites
mache ich hier einfach mal einen pinken
payne backe drauf und einen grauen dann
habe ich diese beiden farben da kann ich
beispielsweise die pentax haben sich
jetzt auch von selber erklärt habe ich
auch gesagt wenn man sich die kräfte
diesmal sogar und da kann ich jetzt
beispielsweise wieder mit dem small
brasch draufgehen und ihr seht bei der
tab palette die grüne farbe ist oben das
heißt neben den small brasch und ich
kann hier etwas grün ist dann
beispielsweise in die ecken malen malen
wir jetzt mal einfach hier als wäre das
sonnen von so alten briefen aber dass er
auch mal so dass einen komischen ecken
noch so schlüssel teile waren und jetzt
denke ich aber dass ich jetzt gerne pink
draufschreiben das heißt neben jetzt
dieses teil und ihr seht schon da habe
ich jetzt bin wenn ich jetzt einmal
gedrückt haben ist pink das heißt ich
kann jetzt hier mal irgendwie sowas hin
malen und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mit dieser farbpalette hier drauf gew
tier das ist jetzt ein anderes pink habe
das kann man doch nicht direkt erkennen
aber hier erkennt man und das andere
ding ist jetzt oben jetzt kann ich da so
was hin mal und wenn ich jetzt wieder
auf die farbpalette draufdrücken
beispielsweise mal recht mache ist weiß
oben das heißt ich kann jetzt noch mit
weiß hier wie so was hin malen oder so
und das heißt letztendlich habe ich dann
hier sowas gemalt ab jetzt auch noch
seinen blauen paint backe den packe ich
jetzt hier beispielsweise einfach mal
hinnehmen dann einfach von der palette
mit davon die blaue farbe die blaue
farbe oben und dann kann ich jetzt hier
auch mal eben noch etwas hin mal und
zwar freundes viele haben sich gefragt
wann ich endlich das mache das sieht ein
bisschen scheiße aus zwar dafür haben
jetzt ach ich bin so blöd der razer
schweins faktoren bilden sicherheit
warum ist der acer das radiergummi
schwarz das radiergummi macht einfach
den block im hintergrund also wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise einen canvas habe
und ich packe den an erde dran dann seht
ihr schon wenn ich oben in der racer
nehme ist der oben grün aber unten wird
er dann immer zu brauchen also der wird
dann quasi so wie die erde nachher zeit
und ich würde sagen ich noch mal eben
wieder tagen jedenfalls hat der razer
das ganze dann hier als zugemacht wie
den block also rein theoretisch wenn wir
das in pink wieder weg machen wollen
müssen wir wieder hier bei der palette
pink auswählen ganz einfach unternehmen
wir wieder hier den dings hier
und dann können wir das hier eben auch
so korrigieren dann gehen wir wieder mit
der palette auf das blaue und dann
können wir das jetzt auch wieder perfekt
weiter malen ich versuch das mal eben
dass man das erkennen kann aber ich
glaube das ist eigentlich schon möglich
so ich mal dass es hier noch so ein
bisschen rum eben dann machen wir das
ganze mal hier ebenso angehen wir hier
so ein bisschen nach oben noch bei mir
auch noch hier so ein bisschen dann
machen dich so so zack zack zack zack
zack machen wir das ganze so und da da
dam oder schönes bild gemalt jetzt
könnte ich natürlich noch hier ein wenig
weiß nehmen und das ganze hier noch
sowie view oder mach ich noch hier mit
dem teil hier so ein bisschen weiße
flecken wundervoll ich denke ich habe
euch die modifikation und komplett
gezeigt wenn ich mal hier vorne noch
schauer vielmehr gibt es eigentlich
nicht eigentlich glaube ich sogar
diesmal alles gezeigt nicht so bei den
anderen modifikationen oder teilweise
gesagt hey du kannst immer nur die
wesentlichen sachen vorstellen auch mal
die kleinen bis dahin vor die
hinzugefügt wurden dann habe ich euch
jetzt jeder mit getan mehr oder weniger
ich hoffe es war nicht zu obszön mit den
dingen die ich euch gezeigt habe und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr das
video bewerten würde mit einer positiven
bewertung wird dann sehen wir uns in
einer nächsten video